تعرضت شبه جزيره القرمله التي ضمتها روسيا
تعرضت لهجوم صاروخي هو الثاني من نوعه
خلال 24 ساعه وقد اعلن الحاكم الروسي
لمدينه سيباس ان دفاعات الجويه تتصدت
لهجوم صاروخي سقط حطامه في مرفا المدينه
التي لجات سلطاتها الى تعليق حركه نقل
الركاب في خليج 7 من جهتها اعلنت اوكرانيا
ان الهجوم على القاعده الروسيه بالقرم
استهدف اجتماعا لقياده البحريه الروسيه ما
ادى الى مقتل وجرح عدد من اعضائها بينهم
قاده في اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
معنى من عمان اللواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك اذا هجوم
صاروخي ثان في اقل من 24 ساعه يستهدف
القرن قراءتك
تعثر
العمليات البريه من طرفي الصراع وعدم
تحقيق انجازات
يعتد بها كان لابد من البحث عن مسار اخر
موازي وكان هذا المسار يتمثل في الضربات
الجويه سواء بالطائرات المجنحه او
بالطائرات المسيره الجانب الاوكراني
قدراته الجويه الحقيقيه محدوده مقارنه مع
الجانب الروسي تقريبا تسعه الى واحد
وبالتالي كان البديل المثالي والذي يوفر
له امكانيه الحاق الاذى هو في استخدام
الطائرات المسيره لكن كان هناك اولويه
للاهداف التي يجب مهاجمتها لاعتبارات عده
فكان الخيار الاول والاولوي المطلقه شبه
جزيره القرم لدواعي سياسيه وعسكريه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه والاولويه الثانيه
كانت العاصمه موسكو وان
فشل العديد من هذه الغارات انما نجح اعداد
قليله على مسافات زمنيه متباينه لهذا
السبب
الضربات الجويه مستمره
وستستمر لن تكون الاولى ولن تكون الاخيره
كما ذكرت نجحت اعداد قليله من هذه
الطائرات في تحقيق اهدافها والوصول الى
اهدافها اذا كانت هذه الهجمات تحبط وتصدها
دفاعات الارضيه الروسيه فما هي قيمتها
العسكريه
القيمه العسكريه يعني بالامس تم اطلاق سته
صواريخ على ميناء سيفاستوكل اسقط بناء على
تصريحات الجانب الروسي خمسه
وصاروخ وسط ووصل الى القياده وهنا ندخل في
متاهه التناقض المعلومات الجانب الاوكراني
يقول كان اجتماع لقاده عسكريين وتم قتل
تسعه وفي من لديهم قادر فعلا مثال اخر
فاكثر من محاوله لاستهداف جسر قرش لكن
نجحوا في مرتين سابقتين وبالتالي حتى وان
فشلت هذه المحاولات ومن كل عشره محاولات
نجحت محاوله واحده ضد هدف استراتيجي كجسر
كرش او
بمناسبه فهذا يعني انجاز كبير لا يمكن
تجاهله لاحظي اي طائره تقترب من من اجواء
موسكو يتم اغلاق اربعه مطارات محيطه في
موسكو اذا
قيمه الهدف من في البعد الاستراتيجي
يجعل وصول طائره من اصل عشره او اكثر شيء
جيد بالنسبه للجانب المهاجم اللواء فايزه
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
عمان شكرا جزيلا لك